Over do. You know.
Although.
You know jay and all of us.
You know journal of my name and.
I think i'm involved with the nimbin
adventure in its early in its nascent stages
in sydney when people were beginning to.
Talk about a new new form of arts festival
for university and other students
and i was involved with a mad
mother people who believed
that we had enthusiasm spirit an
adventure to do things differently
and i guess we really. I certainly
believe that we really could.
Bring about social change.
That would make for a better world for
ourselves and for the various offspring
that were beginning to appear
around our feet at the time
and it was a very exciting time
for me and i still hold a lot of
that excitement i still hold a
lot of a lot of that idealism
and i make no apologize. The policies.
I make no apologies for being.
An indian hippy. Ok.
I live by the beach at byron bay now but
i i'm a hippy died and true. You know.
Whatever the expression is and
i've had a lot of enjoyment
and a lot of learning from
those times till now.
People often say have you got any regrets.
About the time you spent at nimbin
and i think regrets my gosh.
Nancy asking a question
like that. I think it's.
It's been a wonderful social experiment
it is a wonderful social experiment
and i really believe that although
lots of the things that we thought.
May occur and some of the social
change that we thought may occur
and be more far reaching
throughout australia
and indeed the world even though those things
some of those things haven't occurred.
I still believe that the
very influential centre
and really does does formulate a lot of
creative change on this north coast area
and throughout the east
coast of new south wales.
Memories of the festival
an image of the festival.
A beautiful place magnificent
weather fantastic hills.
Hundreds of little fire. That night campsites
night spread throughout the valley.
Just directly behind them then it really
felt quite tribal it was very gentle.
Wonderful entertainers and creative people
that were brought in
specifically for the festival
and a lot of wonderful discussions
and ideas it was a very alive time i
mean you could spend from 25 hours a day
discussing interesting. Things
with a number of different people.
It was very very much of
the image of long here
and far out flower folk with women in
long dresses and babies at their breasts
and things like that and of course that
something that i like to talk about later.
It was amazing for me it was amazing to
be able to to live out in a beautiful
countryside area with so
many wonderful people.
I mean i think there's
something like 8000 people.
The estimates are guesstimates
that the numbers who came through the
festival certainly a lot for a little town
like nimbin i mean the streets were just
chock a block with people you can barely
get a vehicle down the street.
I remember sleep pretty tightrope
walking between the tomato sauce
and the nimbin pub juggling burning stick.
It's on a tight rope that the
fellow from a part of the problem
but paul viral knew no this sort of thing
dollar brand playing amazing far out
piano in the jazz piano in
the nimbin hole and i mean.
Philippa t again writing his unicycle
through the streets of nimbin
and down towards the showground the hari
krishnas wandering around singing in the
sleep for hours providing amazing meals
and then the hari krishnas being followed
by a group of sort of far out hippies
with gumboots going harry gumboot harry
gumboot harry gumboot harry gumbleton
everybody tolerating everybody i mean it
really pushed a lot of people's buttons in
terms of toleration i remember the police
attempting to arrest people for drugs
which always seemed to me from my
very close proximity to the event
that it was a plant and basically the
people said no we will control it.
The people are not dealing drugs
it is not a drug scene and.
Just basically issuing the police out
releasing the people who were arrested
or who had been apprehended they weren't
arrested and was a very powerful time
that way.
There was the learning unit where
people would put up interesting areas
that on a blackboard that they
were interested in discussing
or giving a seminar on or whatever
and there was a very alive time.
Lots of wonderful music
here there and everywhere
and we want to say we our extended
family group from the city.
We had set up a large area where
we had a commune or far community.
Kitchen and all our tents all around.
So any time you wanted a little
bit of home hearth warmth
and comfort you could just want there
and be anything from you know half a dozen
people to maybe 30 at meal time around.
And basically for many of us who had been
raised in nuclear families post world war
two nuclear families and
some of us of course
that had the experience of living
community but to live with this big it.
Standard family or tribal
family it was just wonderful.
And it really did did show that
people can live together harmoniously
and happily and creatively
and excited about italy.
It was sure only for a short period of
time and everybody's on good behavior
or on their best behavior
at times like that
but it was a really hopeful
time dutiful. Other memories a.
Teepees covered in thatch
cut from the fields.
Dozens of people wandering around with
video cameras and tape recorders.
I often wonder what
happened to those archives.
Local shopkeepers and local townsfolk
who had been very carefully
and continually consulted about this process
had no idea what they were in for we
had no idea what we were in for
when we started setting it up.
But they were sort of slightly shocked
and bemused most of the time incredibly
tolerant daisy's cafe daisy stewart who is
somebody i would hope
you have talked with.
Was one of those examples of
sheer tolerance the smiths.
Molly smith molly
and tom smith used to live on the main
street in town millions methadose million
time ago said now that's very
charters mother and father
and the chatters are still in town.
With their daughter narrating
their hardware store.
Mollie smith and tom smith sitting
right in the middle of it.
Their little bent wooden chairs right in
the the entrance to their once shop now
then house which is now than in the
gallery and second hand goods gallery.
They would sit there and they would
say things like you want to be there.
This is the best colour television
in the whole of the world and
that they sincerely believed it
and they were they were happy.
I mean a lot of the old
timers as they were called.
Although then used shocked
people you know scared
or whatever were really delighted
to see their dying town. Really.
Re generating you know so many of
those older people they had seen.
Many of their children or their and
that grandchildren move away from the area
because there's nothing holding them in
them
but it was a dying rundown falling to
pieces old wooden buildings town very quiet
for the passer by. But any
teenage kids living there.
It was like death
and so to see this new energy coming a lot
they had no idea what it was about a way
it was heading. They were really quite
supportive because they could remember.
For example where we lived in paradise
valley where we have entry we bought land
just before the festival.
At the end of crofton road under blue knob
where we live we were the last people
along the road. Now that
there were where we believe.
Many years ago 20 italian families
beyond us into the valley living so
that no had seen very populated times and
then people had wandered away again.
It was a big part of the dairy industry
up in part of the logging industry.
We were the new migrant push for sure.
And we was probably in many ways as many
of us was disrespectful as any migrant
push or invasion. And now the
word was we were very respectful.
I was really happy to be associated
with the people of paradise valley and
that was my extended
family for many many years
and many of those people still
are maxed in the family and.
Because we always we made a policy of
really informing people about what we were
about we felt that information.
What was part of our political ideology
that if you have full information then you.
You don't get into trouble because everybody
has the full information people are
free to make decisions with full information
so we decided almost as a policy it
wasn't a written policy
or anything like that
that we would tell all our neighbors
and locals about who we were
and what we were about and we found that
by opening ourselves up to people like
that they were very welcoming
totally supportive of us.
I mean the generosity that we received
when we first moved to the area was was
almost embarrassing for many years.
I mean we go and visit our next door
neighbors sloane dudley harris.
You know totally raw you know hippies
from the city come to sort of you know
survive on the land. The typical image
and they would give us we would
walk away with ducks and chalks
and fresh vegetables from the
gardens and preserves and jams
and i mean it was it was
really embarrassing
and what could you give these people back
i mean you know i raised my first crop of
beans. You know these very excitedly
and sort of was it really appropriate to
take them down to somebody who's not just
beans but 17 and things like that.
You know another others all sorts of funny
stories come to my mind you know real
new style to stuff like. Tell about
the chalk tell it about the chook.
Ok so we decided to raise chalk because
we wanted to have fresh eggs free range
fresh eggs took us to eat.
So we acquired from charlie soured who
was the local tip man who's quite a
character who i hope you've
encountered who was the chook.
To king basically of the whole region.
We acquired 5 2 wks and at
that stage we had no road to drive up to
our humble dwellings so we had to walk up
a very steep hill across the
creek and up a very steep hill
and in the heat of summer.
John and i carried in his bags these took
a very quick to put chocks impatient
but what about them you know
we carried them up the hill
and finally got them up there and
when we liberated them into their newly
created chook pen with beautiful he touches
like you know gold doors
and things like that
and rainbow rambo signs over the door.
You know i mean we really wanted to welcome
our children. One of them had died.
God what do you do with the chalk.
Well this chick was perfectly alright
before we had begun our scent.
So i trudged over to our
neighbours which you know probably
that quarter of an hour to walk
over there or something like that
and it flood what i do with a
truck that's. Do you think.
Well it's alright you pluck it. Yes
i know but how do you pluck it.
So she sort of told me how you plucked it
and so i then tried to back up the hill and
five. Chalk with pliers we're pulling.
Herself. Look at i'm thinking
this is a self-sufficient.
She had a mission to tell me that
you plunge the chalk in hot water.
She had assumed that i thought.
This basic thing so eventually i
think i'd gone back to ask her again
and so i'd learnt
that yes you plunge the talk about water
because i'd put it in boiling hot water
for too long so by the time the feathers
were plucked out this chook was peeling
and battered.
And then you know had to gut it which was
something i hadn't encountered before.
I mean. I can remind john and i laughing
hilariously at the time at ourselves.
But also there was a slight
element of despair you might.
So we were very raw but very very
enthusiastic and we were quite determined
that we were going to get there. When
it's cut that well i think about it.
With a hard time living in than being hip
in the community members of course who
are hard times.
It's funny how things you know like you
tend to repress the unpleasant memories.
I don't think i've done
that i think i just put them into
a different kind of perspective.
We lived community and the household
that harry in this and john
and i built became the
community households many more
and as people built their houses
many of them used our kitchen
and bathroom as their kitchen
and bathroom while they were
establishing their own and it was really
that the community's main
house for many years.
Everybody would pass in and out of it
and it was nothing for
us to have 20 people.
Do you know it was a frequent event
and that was a very happy event
but it was also a very energy
consuming event we had lots of kids.
We had a very good ratio of adults to kids
that is we had many more adults to kids
very healthy really relationship i think in
that it meant there were usually.
Every kid always had some adult.
Happy to be available to them you might
be getting on particularly well with your
mum. Well you just could avoid her and go
and spend some time with somebody
else who welcome you with open arms.
So the kids had a good time of it and
i think we all i think i did too
that the hard times were
working out the the stresses
and the difficulties we were very
functional i think in terms of.
Avoiding the sorts of stresses
that a lot of shared household
or community households often encounter.
I mean we just had guidelines
you know wasn't the rule.
It was just how we accepted it.
Each other's lives and how it come
to live together over many years and
that was because we lived together
in a city many of us before that.
You didn't leave you washing up
on the sink things like that.
So you never we just had
that as sort of base.
So we never had that kind of stress
or who used to need to wash up there was a
it was a great spirit of generosity with
the people that i did
with an early years and
that spirit of generosity
was very important.
The spirit of generosity towards each other
as adults spirit of generosity towards
each other's kids spirit of generosity
towards each others friends and relatives.
Some of the hard times i think for me
were not having enough space to take my
space away my privacy and i don't necessarily
think that's anybody else's fault.
Other than my own for not wanting to i don't
want to miss out on any of the action
in a way and none of us did. We had lots
of issues to work out of the ground money.
What's equal were some of us went out to
work in fairly highly paid jobs others
others of us were staying
home and building.
Or being the home people what where is
the equity there we never really fully
address those issues and they
were some fairly hard times
when relationships altered
and many of them broke up.
Which is not an honest unusual
event for any body in those eras
or now even they of course you know if
you were in a personal relationship
that was in crisis because
that affected everybody else
and they were so very difficult
times for us as community members.
It was hard building a you know physically
getting out there and building fences
and bridges
and houses from by a load of people
who basically be in academics.
I think we were academics and continued
although we had our sort of activities
that we did many of us have continued
to be in that sort of line
that were there originally. So
you know they were had time.
There was some very heated.
Times around how do you
discipline children.
And
that was a very interesting thing about it
was hard at times it was a very again the
spirit of generosity was there
and a lot of people found it difficult to
have a non-biological parent for example
interact with their young child
in the decent disciplinary
or limit setting type of way and. I
mean i think i learned very quickly.
I've had the privilege of living with
young children before i had my own
and so i had been in that role of being
prepared to be committed to children in
that way of setting limits because it is a
commitment to be prepared to go through
the thick and the thin not just to think
and not just to be nice friends all the
time so the time my kids came along i was
more experience with that but to
watch somebody else disciplining
or setting limits with your own child
which may be a raging battle between a
stroppy 4 year old and a fairly
adamant adult and trust that process
and to know
that those two people had a commitment
particularly adult to the child commitment
kids never had any
difficulty committing them.
Well to anybody that would love
them but to watch that and know
that the adult was so
committed to the child
that even if they were
in a stressful situation
that they would with their
own space and time.
Come back to being with that child
sitting that child on their knee loving
that child and coming back
to the loving relationship
and letting what had passed
be passed so that was.
Although that could be seen as difficult
i saw some of our best growing times
and in later years.
Some people who came to the community
with older children who hadn't had
that experience of having the kids
communards children from very from birth
or from very early on i think found
that very difficult and i found
that more stressful than anything that
ever occurred for me with my kids
and it's really interesting to see how
social conditioning gets laid down very
easily and very early.
Like i think jonah's a very good example
and sally's a very good example
of kids who were commune kids
and really assumed that any adults
that were around were available to them
they really weren't kids who went through
that and now i want me
to get me at the drink
or sort of phase if there was an adult
or a taller pair of legs basically
around who can provide for them
that particular need they
would ask for it and.
So some of those difficulties of people
working out their relationships to children
and things like that may
have been difficulties
but the the long term effect was a
very positive and a very healthy one.
I believe.
So well for me i was prepared to
put pretty well everything up for
grabs. Theoretically anyway.
I think it's taken me a long time to even
consider some of the areas that i didn't.
It i think you needed analysis
of the time that still do.
Yeah i mean just being i was an
urban dweller all of my life.
And to move to the country was a
very expansive experience for me.
You just the space the freedom that
that gave me i could decide what to build
wherever i liked that was fantastic.
So on those sorts of physical
parameters it was very new
and i could make up anything i wanted
to i wanted to build a large house
that sort of had separate units
to most of connected by walkways
and lots of people could
happily ever after living it.
So i decided to do it you know i mean i
was sort of fairly fearless in that way.
I thought because we'll do it
now when we went to council
and said you know these are our building
plans you know we're doing it the right
way we're doing it by the
letter of the law and all that.
So i think i said oh no you
can't do that and i said well
but we're going to you know i mean i
was i wasn't being brash or nasty.
I was just but you know
that's what i'm going to do.
It's you know like
and i sort of said all community health
inspector wally duckling was a real problem
to him. So i learned very quickly.
This man is very good at creating problems
to have the best thing i can do is offer
him the opportunity to solve a problem for
me. So we presented it in that way and.
After many many weeks of dialogue
and negotiation he told us
that we could actually do
exactly what we had on paper.
If we called it something else
and so we had this thing called special
was special residency occupancy buildings
shrubs as they became known.
Thank you very much mr. kling we
said very politely we went away
and what we wanted to do we thought we
were well i was new to create an extended
family. Most of us had come from what we
considered to be dysfunctional families.
But what i considered to
be dysfunctional families.
And we really felt that we could
probably do it better together.
I didn't seem
that difficult a task to live with
people with generous spirit generosity
and to love each other. To like each
other to love each other's kids
and to give kids the opportunity. Instead
of having to be locked in that mum dad
or mom or just dad or just mama
or whatever you know sort of the nuclear
family even if was a single parent nuclear
family rather than being locked in
that to be giving our kids the
opportunity to have a much broader.
Scope of people to choose
their relationships from
and to form their own form in their own
selves from you know i mean i was really
quite happy to have and still them to
have any adults put an input to the kids
and i figured
that they'd make the intelligent choices
along the way as to which were the best
bits of everybody or everybody's attitude
and as a result they probably come out to
be really wonderful people. It's true.
I don't know what i answered
that question driving.
All can i take you up on that.
The statement was that it put a
lot of strain on relationships.
I don't know that that's true.
I think living successfully
with any partner is quite an
energy an emotion consuming experience.
And i learned a lot from those times
because i not only was in a relationship.
But i had the opportunity to view it
very close quarters other relationships.
It's true
that many of those relationships most
of those relationships no longer exist.
But is
that statistically different from anywhere
else at you know i don't think it is not
my observation i can remember reading
statistics in the 70s where.
From the north coast area which i think
said that 60 per cent of school students.
I think it was early high school students
high school students 60 percent of the
students came from separated families.
Now that was at a time that was in the
whole area this wasn't just me but
that was at the time where
it was still considered.
You've had a marital breakdown or
your relationships in that having.
Do you from you from a separated family
are you or you pulled the you know
that kind of attitude was still prevalent
even though the statistics were to the
contrary. And i can remember i think
harry coming home with that statistic
and that's discussing it and
having a good ole chuckle knowing
that you know we had many friends and
selves who were in that category
that we were actually in a majority
as distinct from minority when once
that occurred. So the actual question
that it put a strain on relationships.
Of course would put a
strain a you know a strain
that nuclear families don't have
but it also contributed so
much more to us as individuals
and in a way i think it gave many of us
the freedom to move apart from each other
and still try to start try to maintain
civil friendly relationships.
You don't live with somebody for many
many years and then just suddenly stop
and if you if you.
Born children with somebody
you presumably i mean i'm
and assuming everybody's fairly thoughtful
about their choices you presumably don't
have kids with somebody who you think
that's a little bit more then shipped
or not you know you actually
have some regard and love for
that person at some stage
along the way and if
that no longer is happening it doesn't
mean that you then have to hate
that person or not not have regard
and respect for that person.
So it may have may have
been a contributing factor.
I don't i don't think so and contributing
factor in relationships ending.
But i think it gave us the
opportunity to then go on
and have respect for relationships with
our former partners who were often the
parents of our children.
Polygamy versus monogamy with
with those issues ever resolved.
You know the answer to that that's a yes
and a no. I think for some individuals.
We've been able to come to i mean to me.
For example i have a fairly
clear attitude about my edit
that my stance on it for others.
I don't know whether
they've ever resolve them
or whether it's even a problem for them
and we certainly talked about as you
talk about incest within the snow.
No not insist. Did not insist
that's another issue to talk about.
We talk certainly we certainly encountered
as some of us had relationships with
each other outside of our primary coupling
and most of us were primarily
coupled i might say.
And that created havoc and so there was
an agreement that that we would not do
that.
This is i'm talking about just
that paradise valley i mean plenty of other
situations where people have done that.
It just caused too much stress
and too much lack of trust
and breaking down of too many of
the good things that occurred
and some people never we
could never recovered.
I don't think from some of those
events that the hurts were too great.
And whether we didn't we talked
a lot about that. I mean.
I think my attitude has always been.
I mean i'm a great. Imma go mahn.
Fan
and in the goldman was a feminist american
feminist from the early turn of the century
but.
Before that and century and into the
90s and she believed in free love
and people to say you know
hippies and free love
and i mean i think i do
believe in free love
but i'd like to have the opportunity
to say what i mean by that.
And by that i mean i think
people should be free to love
and have intimate relationships including
sexually intimate relationships with
anybody that they truly love as long
as it isn't hurtful to anybody else.
And if that if
that relationship is no longer truly loving
then it's presumably appropriate for
that kind of intimacy to change.
And if
that person then forms another really close
bond with somebody else then they should
be free to be able to exercise that or
live that relationship to its full.
Well if it which may also include
which may include sexual intimacy.
So that's what i mean by free love.
I don't really have any attachment to
people staying together for the kids for
example i don't think that free love means
that you don't make those choices
without a great deal of thought care
and consideration. Building my own home.
I'd like to tell you why
i built my own home.
I'd started off my university
career as an architecture student
and i decided i didn't want to be a
designer of ticky tacky little boxes
and maybe putting pink or gray
color schemes rather than blue
and brown into government
toilets and things like that.
I mean i was an i was
raised in the era of watson
and i realize i miss i was sick tech you
know i would just be a very ordinary
architect. I didn't think i was really
spectacular in the architecture.
So i decided not to continue with architecture
so i decided i'd really like to be a
carpenter and i went along
applied to do carpentry
and joinery through the
type system and was told
that there weren't enough toilets which i
didn't exactly understand since part of
that story is that they
thought i was missed.
I thought they thought i was mrs. watson
coming along for my dutch speaking husband
who couldn't understand
english when it became clear
that i was actually jammed all
over and i wanted to do carpentry
and joinery then i found out that they
were not enough to put it in the college
and i didn't really think
that this particular bureaucratic
problem had much to do with me
and then i realised what the message was
that we don't want women
girls doing architect.
Doing carpentry enjoying we don't
want girls doing carpentry injuries.
So i sort of.
Was a bit overcome and i very sheepishly
sort of crawled away from that.
So i guess you could say
that i had this deep seated desire to be
involved with building from a very early
age and when i moved to the.
Country it was an opportunity to fulfill
that i went into industrial design
after that and psychiatric nursing
and all sorts of things but
when i moved to the country.
He was my opportunity to
become involved in buildings.
So i was very passionately and
and closely involved with the buildings
of our forces the building of our first
house which was our large extended house
and i found it very tiring
and almost impossible to build physically
while i was pregnant with cell.
I suffered a great deal of twenty
five hour day morning nausea surely
and i'll turn.
And i did a lot of the organization
a lot of decision making
but i didn't do much hands on
stuff. When sally and john is dead.
John and i decided to separate and
move further apart from each other.
The obvious solution came
to me one day and that was
that i should build my own space
and i can relate to the community how
still as long as we had our own spices we
were could co-parent the kids underneath
the same sort of. Under the same half.
I mean you know under half but anyway.
And so i decided to call myself a
house or announce to the family
that that's what i was going
to do and everybody went home.
So i did and i set myself a time limit.
I decided i would build a house in 12 months
working three days a week which meant.
I needed to arrange three days
child free time to do that.
So i did so it was interesting for me
because lots of issues were involved.
It was me as a young mother beginning
to negotiate child free time.
Although we were very committed to the
notion of us all being equal i was
discovering that once you had children.
A lot of those ideas sort of
slipped out the door a bit.
It was one of the issues for me
but i wanted to have that in
that respect of equality.